ready 1 2 3 that was good good stuff
today's video comes to you in two parts
although the first part has like three
sub parts so the structure is gonna
actually be pretty cool uh uh video
intro you do not get to cut me off just
because I'm being boring let me finish
oh all right fine
part one eight eight oh eight and by the
way if you're wondering why I'm not
talking about the gravitational miracle
that is my hair today it's because when
I talk about it it gets puffier on
August 8 2008 at 2:00 p.m. I'm going to
be at the Herald Washington library in
downtown Chicago at 2:00 p.m.
I'm gonna be talking and signing books
and giving stuff away and because this
coincides at the Harry Potter conference
terminus many special guests will be in
attendance like secret brother Adam and
secret sister Rosie Anna and 80% of the
five awesome girls and 20% of the five
awesome guys and one very special
surprise guest who just called me to
tell me he was gonna be there maybe my
hair is being like this because it's
scared of all the awesome then at 4 p.m.
when I finished we're all gonna head
over to Grant Park to listen to wizard
rockers Leanne and Lina and possibly a
very special guest play music then at
8:08 p.m. on 8 808 I and hopefully many
other nerdfighters will be joining Amy
Krauss Rosenthal in Millennium Park at
the bean which by the way is the best
public sculpture in American history
that's right I said it sorry Washington
Monument but you got pwned by a
beautiful silver bean so anyway at 8:08
p.m.
Amy Krauss Rosenthal is going to do
something awesome with all of us at the
bean part two audiobooks so Hank this is
me recording the dedication and the
author's note and the acknowledgments
and Paper Towns in fact I'm going to be
reading your name and also I'm going to
be saying the word nerdfighters so I
went to grant even to see the Paper
Towns audiobook recording but then I
also got to get like a whole tour of the
process of making an audiobook which is
amazing like I got to watch this guy as
he turned extremely complicated dials
and I got to watch this guy as he edited
down all the weird breaths and burps and
stuff and then I got to go into the
actual plant where they make the actual
like physical goods by the way Hank look
at that remember that I bet there is
someone watching this video some young
nerdfighter who literally does not know
what that is they're like is it some
kind of early zip drive sort of but by
far the coolest thing of the trip was
being able to listen to Dan John Miller
the narrator of my audio book as he
actually recorded it stand still while
mortals walked past and then we were too
far past her too many people walking
between her and me Hank I don't know if
you know Dan John Miller but he's in the
band Blanche which is one of my favorite
bands in the entire world he was also
Luther Perkins and the movie walked the
line in fact Hank he'd like to say hello
hey how are you sir
Hank I cannot tell you how awesome I
think Dan John Miller is but when I
first saw him in the studio with
brilliance I did think I'm gonna kill
that guy and take his suit all right
Hank I'm gonna stop now so we can listen
to Dan play one of my favorite songs for
a little while I'll see you in Chicago
[Music]
I never reads away
yeah
[Music]
hey guess who came to visit me in Spring
Lake gentlemen don't yet Hank it's a
Toby in it how did you thought that
lovely woman is evil